ونرويه الى الاخبار العاجله التي بدانا
بها هذه الساعه قصف اسرائيليه في خان يونس
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه استهدف منصات او
خليه للسرايا القدس الجراحه العسكري لحركه
الجدول الاسلاميه كانت تستعد لاطلاق
صواريخ ومصادر محليه فلسطينيه تقول ان هذا
القصف اسفر عن شهيد واصابه حرجه جراء
القصف الذي وقع فيه خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه ومعنا من غزه مراسل الجزيره وائل
الدحدوح نبدا بهذا القصف ما المعلومات
المتاحه عنه حتى الان
حسب اخر المعلومات
والمنسوبه الى مدير مستشفى الاتحاد او
الاوروبي في خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه فان
الحديث يدور عن شهيد واصابه حرجه جدا نقلا
من مكان الاستهداف في منطقه حبسان شرق خان
يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه وحسب شهود العيان فان
الاستهداف كان لعدد من المزارعين الذين
كانوا يقومون بعمليه حصاد القمح في
مزرعتهم في هذه المنطقه خصوصا انه لم تصدر
حتى الان ايه بيانات عن اي جهه فلسطينيه
تتحدث عن وجود خلايا لها في هذه المنطقه
لكن هذه المنطقه زين العابدين هي منطقه
زراعيه في في غالبيتها
وبالتالي ربما قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وطائرات الاستطلاع المسيره التي
بكثافه في سماء محافظات القطاع تشتبه باي
متحرك في هذه المناطق اي كائن حي يتحرك في
هذه المنطقه تشتبه به ولذلك قد يكون
الاستهداف جاء نتيجه اشتباه بانهم خليه
تتبع لاحد فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وكما جرى بالامس زين العابدين اذا كنت
تذكر عندما تم استهداف ايضا في منطقه
القراره وهي منطقه قريبه من مكان
الاستهداف اليوم
والمنطقتين تقعان شرق خان يونس جنوبي قطاع
غزه قالت قوات الاحتلال بانها استهدفت
ايضا نشطاء من سرايا القدس وحينها ربما
ترددت شائعات كثيره ومعلومات مغلوطه كثيره
لكن سرعان ما نفت سرايا القدس ان اي من
الشهيدين الذين سقطاي يوم امس كان من
اعضائها اليوم قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بطبيعه الحال قالت بانها استهدفت خليه
القدس ثم عادت وقالت بانها استهدفت خليه
كانت على مقربه من مكان اطلاق الصواريخ
ولم
وليست كالروايه الاولى قالت بانها خليه
كانت تحاول اطلاق الصواريخ شهود الاعيان
في المكان يتحدثون عن انهم مزارعون
كانوا يقومون بعمليه حصاد للقمح في هذه
المنطقه القريبه من الحدود وهي منطقه ذات
غالبيه زراعيه كما قلت زين العابدين المهم
ان نتيجه هذا القصف هو
شهيد واصابه حرجه جدا حسب المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه وشهود العيان الذين كانوا في
هذا المكان وبالتالي هذه هي المعلومات لكن
هذا الاستهداف ليس الوحيد كما قال شهود
العيان والمصادر المحليه ايضا كان هناك
قصف مدفعي بالتزامن لمنطقتين اخريتين
الاولى في منطقه القراره شمال شرق خان
يونس والثانيه
شرق رفع جنوبي القط